el objetivo de esta visita era firmar un
acuerdo integral de cooperación entre
ambos países cada vez más cercanos esto
en el campo político en el campo
tecnológico nuclear pero especialmente
en la lucha contra el kobe 19 moscú se
comprometió en enviar más vacunas al
país y desde ya se está planteando la
puesta en marcha de una planta para la
producción de la vacuna cruzada en este
país que debe empezar a operar a partir
del próximo año sin embargo el tema que
dominó la conversación fueron esas
conversaciones que se llevan a cabo en
viena para revivir el acuerdo nuclear
sergi labró fue claro en decir que eeuu
tenía que volver a cumplir con todos los
compromisos según lo estipulaba el
consejo de seguridad de las naciones
unidas o sino en el futuro podrían haber
terribles consecuencias también dijo que
si después se quisieran hablar de temas
adicionales como lo es por ejemplo el
programa de misiles esto ya se hará por
fuera del consejo de seguridad de las
naciones unidas- irán siempre ha dicho
que eeuu tiene que levantar la totalidad
de las sanciones hoy dijo que tiene que
pasar una lista de esas sanciones
impuestas en los 1
años y a partir de ahí ellos van a
empezar a cumplir con esos compromisos
que han ido retrocediendo en su programa
nuclear también dominó la conversación
esas sanciones impuestas ayer por la
unión europea contra generales
instituciones iraníes acusadas de la
represión de las protestas de 2019 y
lávrov dijo que este no era el momento
para hacerlo y que podrían afectar esas
conversaciones que se llevan a cabo en
viena